tellurium is is quite a nice element
here
I saw pick it up carefully tellurium
you've never had anything to do with
it's nothing to do with in my life so
this is a new one for me
this is tellurium powder so let's see
what it what was inside the vial so we
open it and tap out the glass file this
one's going to be stubborn this bell
shaped here is a sample of tellurium the
reason shall I hold it for you
it's a sample of tellurium I'm slightly
cagey about touching this because as I
think I explained with selenium that if
you ingest till your room into the body
it can get into your sweat and make you
smell enough to really drive people mad
and these crystals like this one can be
cut up and mounted into a piece of
apparatus like this so a chemist won't
deal with all the elements on the
periodic table in his career normally no
no very few chemists will we'll deal
with more than perhaps a handful of
different elements so this is the
tellurium and this is again this is very
high standard material three grams of
the tellurium material and you can see
it's a very dark powder at the bottom of
the vial it was used in this piece of
apparatus to shining an infrared laser
that's like a heat ray at one frequency
and it came out as twice the frequency
so you can use it to change the effect
of the lated lasers unfortunately the
guy doing it didn't make a very good job
of it and you can see is completely
burnt the surface of this piece of
tellurium so the main use of tellurium
is as components like this for laser
optics and it's not widely used in
chemical industry or similar areas